uh
raquel is with us she is in uh little
rock arkansas hi raquel what's up
hi dave thank you for taking my call
gosh i'm so nervous
that's okay we haven't never we've never
lost a patient what's up
um i filed for bankruptcy
last week and i have
a uh rent-to-own house
like i the contract is pretty much ready
to own
um is there any chances that i can lose
the house
like i all my payments are up to date
and everything i kept the house
and my car out of the bankruptcy
um did you file chapter 13 where you're
paying payments in the bankruptcy or
chapter seven
it's chapter seven okay you didn't keep
anything out of the bankruptcy that's
impossible
everything goes into a chapter seven now
what can happen
is you can reaffirm the debt resign for
the debt on your car
and resign resign for the debt on the
rent to own
if the lender will allow it they
normally
do okay and so what do you owe on your
car
on my car i owe 13 000. what's it worth
uh 10 000 why would you keep something
that's three thousand dollars in the
hole
um i just didn't like it um like i can
pay it off
like pretty quick like if i don't have
you can pay it off
why did you file bankruptcy right well
if i don't have any
uh credit card payments i think that i
can make it pretty quick
what do you make a year uh
last year i made uh 60 thousand
i would recommend you turn the car in
and the bankruptcy and buy you a cash
car
for three thousand dollars yeah okay
um another question about that you're
not gonna do that are you
no well well i think i i
yeah that yeah yeah it's not gonna work
for me
um so the deal is um if if you're going
to keep a bunch of debt
you shouldn't file bankruptcy nope you
should let the debt
go if you're going to file bankruptcy
and you've already filed
and so i would not do what you're doing
i think it's a bad
choice and um i think you're going to
come out of this
with a uh without the you know
the without the freedom that you sought
when you were after bankruptcy making
sixty thousand dollars so and she filed
bankruptcy on a credit card
we don't know how much the credit card
debt is nope but the uh no
so the answer to your question is you
should be able to reaffirm the car you
shouldn't
uh and you should be able to reaffirm
the rent to own and i don't know if you
should because i don't know the numbers
on that
both of those are at the lender's option
meaning the lender could
the landlord on the rent to own could
decide not to allow the reaffirmation
but when you file bankruptcy everything
you have is in it
whether you listed on the matrix or not
it's technically part of the bankruptcy
and you need to get reaffirmation on it
and if your lawyer didn't tell you that
you got one of those lawyers now dave on
a rent to own part this is
uh education for myself she's still
renting
so does she still have to get that
reaffirmed with her just only
the owning portion the contract okay the
contract yes even if you're a renter
um you're you can bankrupt on your
landlord
oh and the landlord if you don't pay the
rent and keep the rent current
and then agree to see any legal money
obligation you have or most any legal
money obligation you have is released
okay okay that would include rent i did
not know that so you're out of your
lease
wow if you you know you could break the
lease in the bankruptcy
and not owe a dime but if you want to
resign the lease
yeah and and you're not and you are
current and the landlord wants you to
then that's fine
and if you want to resign the to own
portion
leasing with an option to own a portion
then you would do that as well most of
those you're paying
more than you would be paying in rent to
be an owner later
which you shouldn't be doing if you're
broke you shouldn't be doing it all
yeah it's not a good plan generally but
don't do that if you're broke so
the thing is if you're broke enough to
file bankruptcy don't keep a car payment
and don't keep an extra high rent
right because it gives you the
possibility of owning later yeah so what
she's trying to do is just get rid of
the
things that were bothering her and
keeping the other things
which were actually the things that are
weighing her down mathematically yes
and that's why you're not listening when
i'm telling you what to do
then you're not going to get the result
you want out of this
because you can't you know
the credit cards are the ones calling
her and pestering her but the big
freaking car payment at the high
interest rate and the overcharged rent
for the rent to own
are what are draining our bank account
yep and those are things you should see
you smack the mosquitoes and the buried
you yeah
you know instead of shooting the bear
and not worrying about the mosquitoes
yeah that's the problem and that's what
happens oftentimes we go in and reaffirm
everything
and of course child support irs student
loans
uh alimony are not bankruptable anyway
right you're gonna be with they're gonna
be with you forever anyway
and so i've had people that file you
know they got a 28 000
irs lien uh that's not bankruptable and
five thousand dollars worth of
credit card debt and they want to file
back and it doesn't you know
you're swatting it mosquitoes and the
berry chip oh you forgot the right
you're
dealing with the bronx the big problem
was never addressed yeah
and if she keeps both of these deals
then she's kept the big part of the
problem
i'm guessing that the credit card i
didn't get that far in it because i'm
not going to argue with a caller
yeah tell you to do something either do
it or don't